yeah that one that's where it goes over
the line for me you know let me ask you
um are you familiar with
Glimpse I've heard of it but I don't
know what it is so Glimpse is an
application that allows you to send
either broadcast out to a large group or
to individuals your current location and
so it's a glimpse into where I am and
you can put a kind of expiry tag on it
so I'm willing to share with you my
current location for the next 15 minutes
MH um and it's real time right it's GPS
based and so you can literally watch me
moving across the map we've talked about
you know the kind of functionality
whereby um again based on location and
where I'm supposed to be the calendar
will know that I am going to be 15
minutes late for my meeting give me the
ability to share a glimpse with your
meeting inv right so you're sitting in
the restaurant and you're waiting for me
I have the ability to say to you Don I'm
going to be you know I'm here now and
you're going to watch me make my way to
our location but it's estimating I'm
going to be 10 minutes late MH can you
see that being useful functionality in
terms of well sure but only to a very
select group of sure people right so
whereas with Facebook um you know you're
making new friends and you're pretty
open about who you friend with um four
square yeah agree no agree no it's got
to be really really close friends you
know otherwise I don't want them knowing
where I am right but I'm perfectly happy
to go on Twitter and say I'm at the tech
crunch conference or I'm here I'm there
that's that's fine because I'm opting to
do that but I don't want to have to
remember in Four Square uh you know that
I'm saying I'm here I'm here I'm here uh
or I guess even with four square though
you're opting into checking in right
it's just that I have to remember who's
following me on Four Square
uh no that's too too close so we we um
we we just implemented a feature we
don't know how people are going to use
it where um you can do a connection with
your Force square and tungo will
automatically check you in based on your
locations yeah so I'm really curious to
see first how many people are going to
enable it yeah and second if
and second if people will like it we
just it took us half a days of work to
integrate and just want to see how
people are going to use that because for
us what what's interesting for that is
that I mean we're pushing out to Four
Square the the location and then
eventually then the idea is to get also
Force grrip to push in information into
us which is POS maybe I'm overly
sensitive
to I don't use the cuz I know I like
Four Square for um I I'm traveling all
the time so I'll the four square will go
to Twitter and I'm on Twitter and I see
some of my friends they're on the same
flight like Boston sancisco oh cool so
I'll go on the plane and find them
because some of my friends are on the
plane I think oh that's cool right or
I'm at a conference and people say that
they're Oh okay that's cool uh so I kind
of like that uh and I just haven't
gotten into the checkin thing about well
sorry the you know the the assistant
check-in um that we're talking about in
tongo is really targeted towards I think
you know first of all four square users
right who are Avid about checking in two
reasons one they want the world to know
exactly where they are and when um and
again a different mindset right but
they're also playing up there's the
whole loyalty component behind for
square also right where brands are now
starting to um reward people whether
it's through mayorip or frequent visits
that are they're starting to reward you
with loyalty points right four square is
the way that they're keeping track um so
the assisted checkin is really targeted
towards the people who are users of for
square but frequently forget to check in
right which happens to me all the time
yeah um I'm using the application but I
will frequently forget to check in and
so damn somebody else will take my
mayorship away at Starbucks or whatever
the case is yeah um so you know it's a
little gimmicky whether like Markus
saying people use it we don't know um
but again it comes back to here's an
application that really does belong in
the calendar because it is event based
and it is location based yeah let me add
to that one of the things that I've done
and it's just you know kind of testing
and playing with things is I've pulled
the four square data string overlay it
on my Google Calendar right so now
you've got appointments but you've also
got location and time stamps yeah and so
you've got a little bit of an
interesting visualization there and so
some of the things that we've talked
about that kind of Dov tail into that is
imagine a situation where you're
attending a conference it's an all day
conference but you've got some scattered
appointments in there as an example
you've got a 10:00 appointment uh but
you show up at the conference at
10:15 you check in one of the things
that it should offer to do is you've got
these three appointments we know you're
running late as a result of the time
that you've marked that you showed up at
the event you want to reshuffle your
calender you want to notify your
contacts these are some of the things
that we're thinking about at least Rob
other than okay I'm at McDonald's and I
want my free coffee right so it relates
much more to time and
location so I think if I were a four
square user I would want every check-in
I make to automatically get onto my
calendar because of that analytics then
I can go back and see has some really
rich metadata as well I I don't know how
much you use for square but you've got
location but then you can start adding
tips right so I'm at this restaurant you
got to check try out the veg
cheeseburger M right so now you're
starting to get some flavor and some
color about the individual and that
metadata is really rich as so automatic
from four square into the calendar cool
love it automatic from my calendar into
for not so cool I hear you not so cool
with that right uh but automatic the
other way that'd be great get the API
pull it in put it on the calendar then
it shows up in your analytics about you
know where you were and I think that's
pretty cool right on so um you know this
is more for off camera but shut them off
no but I mean we can just not use it but
my point is if you look at our road map
what we're
doing um so we've got our top leadership
where you know we can be five years 10
years whatever from now even a year
there's certain things that we can do
sooner than later but what's important
for us in terms of building what we've
got is first the aggregation of
data to to be able to get all these
sources whatever the source may be be
where as soon as there's intent there's
location and there's people it should be
somewhere in your calendar and then and
then from there you start being able to
give some really interesting analytics
to the individual and maybe and we got
to be careful in terms of the the line
here to the Enterprise for them to be
more intelligent of how they're dealing
because at the end of the day usually
the calendar is imposed by your
corporation you're going to be using
Google Calendar right you're going to be
using you know small organizations maybe
not but larger organization it's imposed
so um so giving the organization tools
so that they can also be more
intelligent of how people are using
their times and analytics so you've got
that layer then you've got the extra
layer um which is actually our
foundation which is helping people be
more productive with their time easily
scheduling their meetings offering like
core application core services that
existing calendars are failing to offer
today mainly because they are not
crossplatform cross company it was meant
really to work in silos and that's
Foundation to our business where you
know yes we're aggregating all that but
at the same time we're helping people be
more productive and and so on by easily
scheduling meetings and so on that's the
hook the pain point that everybody's
feeling today that we're solving and
then when you start adding analytics
people say wow I didn't know I could do
this even more and then then you can
start opening their minds to new things
and then from there the layer on top is
you know all these additional stuff that
you can do by offering services and and
other things that you can do from the
calendar that should remain in there um
but even even like and the bridge to me
between the uh analytics to the services
is
um policies within organizations that
restricts people to use certain types of
services if you go to San Francisco you
got to book it in this hotel these
hotels you got to use this Airline and
so on so allowing these corporations to
to push those services to their
employees via the calendar because
that's where they're going to have to do
all their scheduling anyways and then
from there to the individual you can
start also proposing other types of
services so you can see kind of the map
that we see how we're going to evolve to
that how long is it going to
take we'll see but I mean we've got
enough in the next six months with just
the aggregation and the analytics and
some some really cool tools for the
scheduling component like the location
buffering and so on like allowing some
personalization in terms of uh look and
feel where you work for a certain
Corporation when you're sending someone
to a page you don't want necessar to
send them to tungle mege you want to
send them to Google schedule. google.com
Doge and have a bit of Google branding
or your own branding or whatever but so
there's a lot of things that we can do
just on the scheduling still that
there's a lot to do there so that's our
going to be our Focus for the next six
to 12 months well makes sense you know I
think uh being a thought leader is
critically important because uh people
do buy Vision um you know sure they look
at features and functions and when
they're comparing three or four
companies and okay they're all about the
same but I like this Vision so I'm going
to go in this direction because I want
to get on this train yeah because I like
where it's going so vision is important
and road maps are important and I think
too many companies startups particularly
focus on features and functions today
and they're not telling their vision for
the future and that's you know that's a
differentiating factor and you uh you
like this Vision I do yeah I think it's
great cool yeah can you just talk on
camera 30 seconds about kind of what you
do here and what your role is sure I'm a
developer Advocate at Google so
developer Advocate means that I advocate
for developers uh whatever a developer
needs to get a job done if they need uh
additional features or they need access
to uh beta code or they need uh a vision
on where they things are going then I
advocate for that uh with the
engineering team so that's One Direction
the other direction is uh more of
evangelist where I make uh tell
developers about the new things that
Google is doing and where we're going
and why it's good to get on on board
with us and just uh that sort of thing
so it's a two-way kind of thing with
developers with add in mind what are
some of the most exciting things that
you're that you see happening in the
calendaring space and as much as as the
development Community is concerned is
there anything that comes to mind kind
of to be your tongue that um well no I I
think the free busy time and scheduling
meetings is a pain point and you know
there are three or four companies that
really jumped on that in the past three
years um that so that's a relatively new
phenomenon in the past three years um
done a pretty good job of solving that
problem uh but you guys are really
thinking much further ahead than anyone
else that uh that I've seen in the space
so I I think that's uh critically
important yeah it's about execution on
it you schedule your own time yeah
single biggest pain point if you could
kind of put your finger on about your
calendar and the way you interact with
your calendar yeah it's scheduling you
know even within the company it's um
it's reasonably good uh but once you go
outside the company then it falls apart
and that's why you know tungle is
uh really helpful in that space